hello welcome to this video playing
knock who the heck is knock okay I'm
trying for handshake Pannone and I'm
kind of tired about those time losses so
try to be happy real quickly about it
and not I don't know think for ages why
opponents play some strange moves quite
often there is no ADM but I am I even
simply give them an idea by taking for
far taking far too long okay another
point you will always get back with the
bishop on g2 and the night on age three
and don't have to worry about that
yeah g5 I cannot allow yeah what I'm not
seeing white plain g5 here I mean maybe
can I go Queen h5 something like that
that might be possible ok seems is out
for before stuff
yeah anyway 9 p-5 is a quicker idea
though g5 now okay so we are taking only
have six is some pretty pretty awkward
hmm no wasn't what i have what i wanted
but i guess i have to pay a price for
playing so quickly and I don't do I
don't really expect him to take to be
honest I thought we should have six of
the weird weird move
yeah I'm not quite sure what you should
do queen h5 maybe but then then I'll
take be five maybe rue k5 just keeping
that for the moment maybe tumbling on
the phone no ok I'll [ __ ] age 60 fish
about six screen have 6 mm okay g3 it
gets it gets scary
hmm that is that is scary quite a bit
just giving my king some place to go
maybe I can get it to e7
poo
con takes Queen 86 I know I cannot go
queen of six but I'm not quite sure if
there is ok this is night h7 is going
Queen 83 here I guess
between age seven also still on but it's
no made right
great I don't see any defense to that
see absolutely no defense
maybe I can do this takes takes rook h3g
six I mean added that should lose some
how but I didn't quite see yet how
exactly it should use okay
look aged three might work might work
came didn't do it
Wow time warning does the only thing
that I saw that somehow maybe not
directly made maybe it is somehow but
takes root G to check Bishop every check
for its two losses but then maybe not
check that's kind of check wow I'm not
losing by ever check made it's amazing
at least I don't see how King g3 okay
I'm just I'm just believing him here I
don't have time to figure that out check
haha equal material check check
unbelievable by winning this game and so
completely reverse rules here normally
I'm out playing the guys and then
getting swindled check now let's stop
that check check check yeah I cannot
change him to know Luke ill give the
shakes and check here ahem södra I I
probably cannot even I wrong can take it
now it is a drawer I can only check them
can only check them well after that game
I'm happy I mean I could have one on
time but check check it's just it's it
kind of kind of amazed down yeah that
play quickly strategy backfired I just
had a total wreck of a position and I'm
just wondering so here here g6 and let's
see so this is this is letting me off
the hook the chalice was winning then
taking if i go i know here check check
that's just night takes and I'm out of
I'm out of ideas ma'am can't hear all of
a sudden yeah and I cannot do anything
here this is check losing so I had to do
this and this is equal somehow somehow
somehow swindled out of that or he's
been taught himself out of it oh
whatever ah Wow ok I think I'll need a
break him thanks for watching